hey
or not
um yes i'm here hello okay
okay so our last speaker is uh uh
young stanza who's
remotely coming in from cambridge i
guess
and he's going to tell us how
vasserstein networks can succeed by
failing
thank you
hello can you see my slides
yes yes that's fine
okay perfect
so thank you so much for giving me the
opportunity to speak at this workshop
and today i would like to present you
the research on vassar stengens on which
i have worked with christian edmond lisa
chrysler and karola schenley
so in
in this talk i would like to address uh
two questions first is how well the
vascular strain guns estimate the
cluster stain distance and the second is
uh is faster standing distance even the
good function for that good loss
function for generative modeling
so i would like to start by reviewing
the problem with which vassar stand guns
are trying to solve which is the deep
generative modeling so the goal in deep
generative modelling is to learn a
certain high dimensional probability
distribution from a finite set of
samples from this distribution and
generative adversarial networks known as
guns are one of the most successful
approach to tackling this problem so to
visualize how successful they are here i
show
a couple samples that came from guns so
for example
a sample like like this face is obtained
by first showing gun
a lot of human faces which are samples
considered samples from the distribution
of human faces on the space of all
possible images
then the gun is learning this
distribution and then we can ask it to
generate more samples from this
distribution and in output faces like
this that look very realistic
yet these are faces of people that were
not presented to gun and
in fact
don't exist so you can see that the
network the algorithm manages to capture
some
useful things about the distribution
from the samples
okay so what are generative adversarial
networks so they have a couple
components first oh sorry first of all
there is a latent space which will
denote z and a simple prior probability
distribution on this latent space which
we'll denote as pi
this is usually taken to be just a
multivariate normal distribution then
there is a generator neural net neural
network which maps from the latent space
to space x which is a space in which our
target samples live
so this
this
generator network it takes on the input
samples from the prior distribution and
then transforms them into samples that
look like the samples from our target
distribution which we want to learn
of course during training this um
approximation of target distribution is
imperfect and we will
denote
p theta the generator distribution which
refers to the distribution that the
generator currently knows
uh then there is another network called
the discriminator and the discriminator
takes on the input i
the samples either from the
target measure or from the generator
measure
and then it's trying to tell them apart
by assigning some real number which
sellers as a score
finally there is a value function which
takes the discriminator and the
generator and measures their relative
performance and the discriminator is
trying to maximize these value functions
while the
generator is trying to minimize it so
they play in this adversarial game here
for example we have an uh value function
which has been originally suggested by
ian goodfellow and in that case the
discriminator just
outputs the probability that a given
sample
comes from the target distribution
rather than the generator distribution
and this uh
induces this kind of game dynamics
between the generator and the
discriminator and we hope to converge to
a certain nash equilibria where the
generator produces the samples that are
indistinguishable to the samples from
the target measure and the discriminator
always assigns the same score to both
samples from the generator and the
target measure
so how do we implement this in practice
first of all we optimize this inner
maximum with respect to the
discriminator parameter
with
this inner loop
that optimizes the discriminator so we
sample a batch from our data set from
the target distribution and a batch of
samples from the generator distribution
then we calculate the value function and
run a gradient ascend step with respect
to the generator those sorry
discriminator parameters then we repeat
this process nd times keeping the
generator fixed and then after nd
iterations we sample again about from
the target distribution and the
generator distribution and now we do an
update with respect to the generator
parameters so this inner loop hopes to
compute this maximum and then
we do this
then we do the step with respect to the
parameters of the ga of the generator to
start computing this outer minimum
um at least that's the theory so the
classical point of view on guns
is the classical way of understanding
them mathematically is indeed assuming
that this inner loop is able to find an
optimal discriminator and by this i mean
that this inner loop finds the maximum
with respect to the discriminator
parameters of the value function then we
can call this f of theta and then we can
cast the gun optimization problem as the
minimization of f of theta with respect
to the parameters of the generator and
it was shown that under this assumption
um the gas the gun optimization problem
can be just rewritten as the
minimization of the jensen shannon
divergence between the target
distribution and the generator
distribution with respect to the
generator parameters
so this gives us extremely elegant
formulation of the gun algorithm
as a certain divergence
minimization
unfortunately there are problems with
this point of view
so it has been found empirically that uh
while we keep this nd the number of
iterations of the discriminator to be
something like one then the algorithm
works very well but as we start
increasing the number of discriminator
iterations between each generator
iteration
it actually the performance actually
drops which is completely contrary to
this theory which assumes that we always
find the optimal discriminator between
the
the generator updates
so this
one explanation to this has been
suggested by martin arievsky uh where he
said that in generative modelling
basically he pointed out that we are
usually dealing with measures which are
supported on some low dimensional
manifolds and if the the if the manifold
on which the generator measure is
supported doesn't intersect with
sufficiently with the
manifold on which the target
distribution is supported then as our
discriminator approaches the optimal
discriminator the gradients of the
the gradients of the value function with
respect to the generator parameter
will approach zero so our generator will
not be able to learn
and this is caused because uh by the
fact that the jets and shannon
divergence cannot handle well mutually
singular measures
so if p and q so sorry if um our
generator measure and the
target measure have these joint supports
then
the generation diverges will be always
equal to log of 2 regardless of how far
the supports are from each other and the
same is the case for most commonly used
probability divergences so the idea of
martin ariowski was to fix this by
switching to a vasterstein one distance
which actually decreases smoothly as the
supports of the distributions get closer
together
so he suggested to replace the value
function with this functional that comes
from the kantaravich rubinstein duality
formulation of vassar's lane one
distance and then since uh contra with
rubinstein formulation requires uh
optimization over one license functions
uh he he suggested that we should add
this gradient penalty term to our loss
function which basically analyzes the
discriminator for having norms of
gradients higher than one
and this indeed uh have looked very
promising
as uh now with this new loss function
increasing the number of discriminator
iterations didn't hurt the performance
and actually they managed to report
state of the art
with with this paper
but i think that we need to be careful
here because the fact that this produced
a very good generative model doesn't
immediately imply that
it has succeeded in computing the vassar
stand distance in fact there are three
sources of error in this approximation
which should be examined so first of all
this
optimal f is approximated with a neural
network
secondly these expectations are
estimated with monte carlo based on mini
batches which arrive to us as we iterate
the training of the algorithm and
thirdly the one lipschitz constraint is
only enforced approximately via soft
penalty
so
in our work we have examined how closely
the vassar stand distance is actually
approximated but we realized that there
is some inconsistency in what people
think is the quantity we are trying to
approximate so there are two different
uh um estimators of wasserstein distance
that people are interested in
approximating and i will discuss both of
them so the first one we label the
oracle estimator so in this case we are
which i think is in line with original
idea of martin arievsky we are trying to
find the kantari which potential this
optimal f
uh with respect to the full measure full
distribution
the target distribution and the
generator distribution
but what people also consider in
literature is algorithms which
accurately approximate vaser steam
distance between mini batches as they
arrive during the training iteration so
and this we label as batch estimator so
that means that at each iteration when
you sample too many batches you want
your loss function to reflect the
vassars and distance between these two
minimum batches which you have sampled
so we will argue that vasserstein uh the
the vassar stand gun as suggested by
martin arievsky fails to compute both of
these estimators and moreover that the
second estimator is
undesirable
so first of all
the oracle estimator already fails in
two-dimensional case so what we can see
here is vassar's 10 gun trying to
approximate a 2 dimensional gaussian
mixture the blue dots are samples from
the generator distribution where the red
dots are samples from the target
distribution and we can see on this
logarithmic scaled plot
and the loss of the generator is much
lower than the actual vassarstein
distance which i can compute in this
case because we are in two dimensions so
in two dimensions i can compute the
ground true versus distance based on
finite samples and the rate of
convergence is reasonably good so i will
get very good approximation and i have a
lot of samples
we can see that at the end of the
training although the generative
performance was very good uh the loss of
the vasterstein gun was seven times
smaller than the actual vassar chain
distance so that was very inaccurate
approximation and things only get worse
as we go into higher dimensions as it is
well known that if you want to
approximate one lip sheet functions up
to accuracy epsilon in d dimensions then
you need number of samples that is
exponential in in the dimension of of
your space
so we if we don't make a prior prior
assumptions on uh on our function
that requires really huge number of
samples and if you're interested in
higher dimensional and experiments then
i also invite you to read our paper
where we discuss this in greater detail
um
i would also like to recall some
classical results about the sample
complexity of vassar screen distance
which showed that the vastus and
distance suffers very heavily from the
currents of dimensionality so in
particular if i'm interested in vascular
strain distance between two
distributions p and q
and then i want to estimate this by
taking n samples from p and n samples
from q and then calculating vasorching
distance between these two samples then
the difference between what i have
computed and what i wanted to compute
will be very high in high dimensions and
in particular the number of samples i
need to decrease my
my error up to a certain level uh
increases exponentially as as the
dimension increases
so to visualize what that means in
practice here uh i said the dimension of
our space of interest 20 because this
has been um estimated as a lower bound
for a dimension of manifold of human
faces
and i've put a standard gaussian
distribution there so now imagine that i
want to so now um the the difference the
wasserstein distance between a gaussian
distribution and itself is obviously
zero but if i take n samples from this
gaussian distributions
distribution and then another n samples
from this gaussian distribution and then
i estimate vaser stain distance based on
these two batches of samples
then i will get something that is
non-zero and actually decreases very
slowly with the sample size so if i want
to know
if we want to know what is the number of
samples that we need in order to
for our approximation error to decrease
to 0.1 this is something like over 10 to
25 and if we want it to decrease to less
than 100 then we need more than 10 to 40
samples which is far larger than any
conceivable data set so there are some
fundamental statistical problems here
and there are more arguments against the
oracle estimator so first of all this
oracle estimator only like
only makes sense if we
are thinking about this optimal
discriminator dynamics but they are not
necessarily the right description of
what happens in guns because original
guns although they have probably as
proven by martin ayorowski probably bad
optimal discriminator dynamics they
worked very very well when trained with
few discriminatory iterations
uh so there is a reason why they worked
well which is not this optimal
divergence optimal
optimal discriminator and divergence
minimization point of view
secondly what i think is very
interesting is that adding this gradient
penalty term to the original gun also
helps the performance tremendously and
removes this problem that the
performance drops as we increase the
number of the discriminator iterations
so perhaps what is going on is not that
we are actually that vassar stand gun
computed the vassar's wasserstein
distance but rather that this regular
this lipschitz regularization of the
discriminator helped to preserve the
balance between the generator and the
discriminator and stabilize the training
because adding this penalty to the
original gun which has nothing to do
with wasserstein distance also helps
tremendously and you can see this on
these pictures on the left we have
vasserstein gun with the gradient
penalty which performs very well then
vanilla gun which in this case it failed
to capture the
uh the gaussian mixture distribution but
then as soon as you add a gradient
penalty to this it actually performs
very well as well although it has
nothing to do with with w1
and thirdly there have been large-scale
studies done on uh different loss
functions of
of guns where different guns have been
compared on different data sets and with
different architectures and different
loss functions and the finding was that
guns are very sensitive to the change of
the net neural network architecture of
the discriminator and generator uh but
changing the loss function doesn't
not know of the loss functions
consistently outperforms any of the
others so there is no evidence when you
look over wide ranges of hyper
parameters and data sets that vassar
stand guns actually outperform original
guns
uh so the success of vassar stand guns
may be not due to the good loss function
but carefully chosen hyper parameters
and this lipschitz regularization trick
uh so that's what i wanted to say about
the oracle estimator and now i would
like to move to this patch estimator so
in batch estimator we are interested in
approximating the vasosthene distance
between mini batches as they arrive in
our training iterations
and this has been explored for example
by anton malasto
and he suggested this method called c
transform vegan so here we can see that
the w gun gp again it completely fails
to capture the badge faster stein
estimator
but it produces very good looking
samples whereas the method of molasses
had very good approximation of
stain distance and had
very bad looking blurry samples so this
experiment was done originally by
malasta as well and he also had these
observations here we reproduce his
experiment in higher resolutions and
with state-of-the-art neural network
architecture to see if this finding is
robust to changing resolution and
architecture and we got exactly the same
results as him as him
so now we have this puzzling question
why is this the case that the a method
which has a better approximation of bad
vastus team distance produces bad
samples
and uh to shed some light on this it's
worth looking and this remarkable
similarity between the output of c
transform of vascular strain gun and a
result of a clustering
algorithm
label known as geometric k medians
so what are geometric k medians
the geometric k-medians well first the
geometric median just like the mean is
the meaning of a finite set of points of
euclidean space is a minimizer of the
sum of the squared distances
uh the geometric median is just the sum
of the the minimizer of the sum of the
non-squared distances and just like the
notion of the mean can be lifted to the
k means uh clustering algorithm the
notion of geometric median can be lifted
to the
geometric
k medians clustering algorithm
and now with this we are able we were
able to generalize a result by
kanas and rozako which showed a
connection between vasserstein two
distance and the uh k means clustering
algorithm uh to show that to prove a
connection between vaserscene one
distance which is what is used in vassar
string guns and the k geometric medians
clustering algorithm so what we are
we're able to show is that if you take
the distribution empirical distribution
formed by the centroids of k geometric
medians
then this
uh distribution minimizes the vassar 101
distance
from the empirical distributions
distribution formed by your data set
among all distributions with support
size equal to k
so since our data our training data
comes in mini batches if we take k to be
equal to the size of the mini batch that
means that the
batch consisting of the centroids of the
geometric k medians
is a batch with minimal
one wasserstein distance from the
empirical measure formed by your data
this theorem requires a certain
refinement as in practice when we are
training clusters and guns we are not
comparing our mini batches
versus the whole with the whole data set
but rather we are also taking a mini
batch from the data set and comparing
this
so this is
room for further work to refine this
theorem but we see that empirically this
is also true when you subsample the data
set
when you compare mini batches so in this
experiment we show this empirically we
fix three different batches here the
first batch is a batch of real human
faces second batch is just a repeated
phase which has been obtained as the
pixel wise average of 10 000 faces and
the first batch are is formed by the
centroids of k geometric medians
then each of these batches we compare
with many batches of human faces drawn
from the celeb a data set and we
calculate the average vassar's 10 1
distance
what we find is that the batch of real
human faces has much higher
expected uh
vassars than one distance from other
batches of human faces than the other
two batches in particular the batch
consisting of k-mean centro you can
geometric means millions centroids
indeed has the lowest uh vascular strain
distance from batches of real human
faces so this has some very big
implications for our generative modeling
problem because if you give me two
generators one of them is generating
real human faces and the other one is
always outputting the
uh the centroids of k geometric medians
if i use batch wasserstein distance as
my loss function then
the one that outputs the centroids will
have lower loss than one that outputted
perfect human faces so that means that
that's not a viable loss function and
that perhaps shed some lights on why
molaster's algorithm produced such a
such poor samples
so one might wonder what causes this
problem
and this could be one could think that
this is again sample complexity issue
and in our paper we have uh kind we try
to control for this by examining
entropic regularization and i invite you
to
to read it if you're interested in this
and we found out that it doesn't fully
explain it and what our
conjecture is is that the source of the
of the problem here is a very close
connection of vassar's 91 distance with
a pixel wise l2 distance in fact if you
have two finitely supported measures p
and q with equal size of support so we
can think about this distributions as as
two batches of images
uh then the wasserstein distance uh
between between these two batches of
images
is equal to just a sum of pixel wise
distances between images in the first
batch and the images in the second batch
except that images in the second batch
has been have been permuted
with some permutation sigma which
minimizes this quantity over possible
permutations
uh so but uh so that means that the
vassar's claim one distance is very very
closely related to pixel wise l2
distance but the pixel wise l2 distance
is a horrible metric to compare images
and this is um visualized in this
graphic here
so the first graphic is there is some
reference image the second column shows
the first column shows some references
image the second column shows some
slightly altered but semantically and
perceptually very similar image and the
third column shows an image which is
semantically completely different yet in
l2 distance in pixel ways l2 distance
the third column is closer to the first
column then the second column is to the
first column so if i'm using a pixelized
l2 as my measure of similarity between
images then this insect here is closer
to this mammal here than this mammal
here is to this mammal here which is of
course not kept failing to capture the
cementing and perceptual features of
of these images
um so we believe that in our
remedy vaser stengans
one has to address three issues which
are sample complexity which could be
done by a regular entropic
regularization or some kind of sliced
distances
one has to replace the ground cost the
l2 cost by some perceptually meaningful
distance for example l2 distance between
vgg embeddings or something along these
lines and thirdly one has to address
this issue of the approximation of
optimal discriminator uh possibly by uh
improving the optimization algorithm or
by actually by encoding some prior
knowledge about the structure of the
controversy potential into the neural
network architecture because if you want
to uh avoid this curse of dimensionality
results for ellipses functions we need
to somehow encode the prior knowledge
about the function we are looking for or
restrict the search space otherwise we
will just need infeasible number of
samples
and that is all i wanted to tell you
today if you're interested if that talk
was interesting to you then i once again
invite you to read our paper which is
available on archive now and i also
highly encourage you to read these other
two papers
which also cover this topic and have
been a huge source of inspiration for
our work
and if you have any questions then i am
happy to take them now or you can email
me later under this address
thank you so much
thank you for the wonderful talk uh
comments questions
oh okay okay
yeah thank you very much for the
wonderful talk uh i just want to add
this maybe one more possible explanation
why you see that w1 or russian gun
didn't give you the best image because i
think the entire varsity metric is in
the weak side no matter w1 or w2 it's if
the linearizer is going to be in the
soviet space w negative one p that class
so basically we are using a weak norm
and when you minimize the weak norm to
the minimum you actually have a very
flat bottom and that's why you have a
small small the smaller the objective
function just more smooth you obtain and
we see that uh all the time in some
other applications so what will improve
make it better is to go to a stronger
norm so i think the fact that you have
this combination it probably was uh
you are taking advantage of the w1
the uh geometric feature but in the end
because of the error and over the batch
noise that actually push you
uh in the neighborhood of some stronger
norm that that l2 actually play a role
and that's why you get a better high
resolution image
thank you very very interesting
perspective
yeah thank you also for a very uh
intriguing talk uh
i i would like to somehow understand uh
the following so somewhere in the middle
you basically were replying also and i
agree right that even if you knew the
target measure perfectly and you're
using an empirical measure and you're
pushing it forward the best thing that
you would get are is that your
conversion to these k medians
and as you as you noted both kind of uh
on the images right is that when you
average these images and you obtain the
k median this is no longer on the
manifold of images that you would like
to be at because that's really what
vasinstein measures and you know this
average is going to be off that manifold
so i'm actually you know what is
actually puzzling for me is how could it
possibly work right even with when
you're when i'm making the error what is
that is making this scan when it works
to actually produce things on a manifold
which we don't know what this manifold
is and there is nothing explicitly in
the modeling that is trying to guess
thank you
yes so this is a great question i think
yes so this is uh
this is a great question so
we kind of the title of the talk is that
vassar stand guns work because they
failed to approximate the vassar stand
distance so i also think that the
original vassar 10 gun gp which worked
quite well does not approximate the
vassar stand distance and the question
is okay but then since it worked what
did it do right
i don't think there is a satisfactory
satisfactory theory of this at the
moment uh i mean there is of course some
intuition that you can think that this
discriminator just managed to because
it's
if it's not a vast controversy potential
then it's just some function that
assigns a score it assigns a high score
when things look like faces like
they look like they lie on the manifold
and it assigns low score if they look
like they are not on the manifold
and it doesn't it the connection to l2
is not enforced when we are not
approximating vassarstein distance
so i think that this kind of
heuristic framework is
it kind of allows it to come up with
some more flexible divergence between
probabilities which is learned in a way
with this discriminator network and it's
more perceptual
because this is a neural network which
this convolutional
prior in the architecture of the neural
network allows it to capture
perceptual features well
and then
there is also a good question why it
doesn't uh memorize the training data
right
uh and uh
this is also somewhat mysterious but
this requires i think just better
understanding of over parameterized
systems than we currently have it's a
general question for neural networks
right why they don't over fit although
they could
have that answered the question
yeah
anymore
i have a question so my question is uh
so you said that uh
in a very good way that
you know if the batch size is more
actually you are competing something
else
but uh so if you
if you increase the batch size what does
it happen so you still have these uh
artifacts
some you know these k-means stuff or
maybe if you i don't know i think the
batch sizes usually are 16 or 32 or
something like that if you put like 200
or
300 maybe you know it gets more
complicated and it's not feasible maybe
but uh what what do you get yeah we we
tried with something like 500 i believe
it was the highest i've tried 512 and
you still get blurry looking faces like
looking like k means um centroids uh i
mean
you could ask a question what happens
when you do like full batch optimization
for example
but that's a really very hard to to
check in practice as that would require
a huge gpu memory to run such experiment
and i i i would like expect that it
would overfit heavily to the training
data in that case
let's thank the speaker again
thank
you and i think the public service
announcement was that i think the music
school has a concert now that maybe
people would be interested in but
yeah
so there is an